[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous de débat de chronique et de
reportage sur public scena 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos experts et voici le sommaire de ce
6 décembre ce sont des heures cruciales
qui s'annoncent pour l'Ukraine les
États-Unis mais aussi l'Europe vont-ils
continuer de soutenir le pays dans son
combat contre l'envahisseur russe au
Congrès américain aujourd'hui lors du
Conseil européen la semaine prochaine
les divergences la lassitude des alliés
s'expriment quelles seraient les
conséquences d'un soutien à minima
comment Vladimir Poutine pourrait-il en
profiter on répond à ces questions dans
une minute et puis dans notre second
débat c'est une icône mondiale que je
vous propose de
retrouver les blancs sont nos frères en
Afrique du Sud et ce que nous voulons
c'est qu'ils se sentent en sécurité et
qu'ils ressentent notre gratitude pour
tout ce qu'ils ont fait pour le
développement de ce
pays 33 ans après sa disparition 10 ans
après sa libération j'ai inversé 33 ans
après sa libération 10 ans après sa
disparition que reste-t-il de l'héritage
de Nelson Mandela la nation arc-en-ciel
dont il rêvait c'est-elle perdue dans la
corruption qui entend encore son message
de pardon et de réconciliation c'est un
hommage lucide que nos invités lui
rendront dans trois quart d'heure mais
d'abord donc les dernières nouvelles du
front ukrainien avec un mot sur toutes
les lèvres l'enlisement Jérôme Rabier
l'Ukraine entre en zone de turbulence
après l'échec reconnu de la
contreoffensive lancée en juin vient le
temps des incertitudes pour tenir sur le
terrain l'Ukraine a besoin des armes et
du soutien financier des Occidentaux
mais aux États-Unis le Congrès est dans
l'impasse politique pour débloquer une
nouvelle aide massive de plus de 60
milliards d'euros les républicains
réclamant des contre
le Congrès doit décider s'il continue à
soutenir le combat pour la liberté en
Ukraine au sein d'une coalition de 50
pays oùil ignorera les leçons de
l'histoire et permettra à Poutine de
l'emporter c'est aussi simple que
cela on attend dans cette aide l'Ukraine
tente de résister sur le front mais la
guerre de position ne joue pas en sa
faveur dans le camp russe au contraire
on affiche son
opismes militaires agissent avec compé
ettermination
ô
danses vadimir pe aé la semaine dernière
un décret pour augmenter de0000 hommes
les effectifs de l'armée de la
Fédération de Russie une manière
d'incrire l'effort militaire dans la
durée même l'an qui soutient depuis le
début les forces ukrainiennes semble
inquiète de la situation nous devons
soutenir l'Ukraine dans les bons comme
dans les mauvais moments nous devons
également nous préparer à de mauvaises
nouvelles situation politique ce temps
en Ukraine certains dénoncent les
décisions solitaires du président
Zelenski c'est le cas du maire de Kev
Vitalie klitchko qui parle
d'autoritarisme au sommet de l'état des
tensions seraient également apparu entre
volodimir Zelenski et l'autre homme fort
du pays le général Valéri zalouni
commandant en chef des forces armées
ukrainiennes qui a osé évoquer l'impasse
dans laquelle se trouve la
contreoffensive ukrainienne dans des
médias
occidentaux quelles seraient les
conséquences d' un désengagement
occidental les soldats Ukrainiens
peuvent-ils encore gagner la guerre on
en débat tout de suite avec Emmanuel
dupui bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
président de l'Institut prospective et
sécurité en Europe et enseignant en
géopolitique Mariana pé benessou bonsoir
et bienvenue à vous vous êtes
journaliste franco-ukrainienne vous
collaborez à l'hebdomadaire ukrainien
ukrainski tisden et au médias en ligne
desk Russie Patrick Martin jeunier
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
professeur à Sciences Po spécialist des
questions européennes votre livre l'UR
Europe a-t-elle un avenir publié chez
studirama et Mathieu croissandau bonsoir
mathieualiste politique bienvenue à vous
Emmanuel du pluie il y a peut-être pour
commencer un un constat d'échec à faire
celui de la la contreoffensive
ukrainienne on peut le dire clairement
aujourd'hui bah disons que les
espérances que nous avions quand elle a
été lancée en juin dernier se sont
révélé peut-être en de ça de résultats
attendus puisque il n'y a pas eu une un
gain significatif de territoire
contrairement à la précédente offensive
septembre de l'année dernière où un
certain nombre de territoires ont été
reconquis par les troupes ukrainiennes
euh deuxème on en attendait
trop disons que on en attendait beaucoup
si nous avions répondu concrètement à la
demande des Ukrainiens c'est-à-dire si
nous avions livré l'ensemble des
matériels militaires que nous avions
promis si on prend juste l'immense
majorité des matériels qui vientnent des
États-Unis États-Unis d'ailleurs on va
en parler ont livré depuis le début du
conflit 111 milliards d'euros de
d'armement sauf qu'ils l'ont pas livré
avec la même efficacité et la même
célérité là actuellement on est pour le
mois de novembre à 530 millions
seulement 10 % du haut du spectre 6
milliards en janvier de l'année dernière
ça veut dire qu'il y a eu une baisse
constante et donc sans doute des
attentes de la part des Ukrainiens qui
n'ont pas été à la hauteur de leurs
espérances ensuite le deuxème élément
c'est que l'hiver s'approche donc il est
aussi je dis pas normal mais en même
temps attend d que ce front se fige ouis
de part et d'autrre maintenant votre
reportage a très bien évoqué le yatus
qui existe entre les deux les deux
fronts ou les deux les
deux les deux camps l'Ukraine a besoin
de recruter des hommes et de disposer de
matériel avec une urgence aussi forte
que du côté russe mais les Russes ont
une capacité de masse une capacité de
recrutement vous avez évoqué les 170000
hommes 15 % de recrutement en plus alors
que les Ukrainiens sont sans doute de ce
point de vue là un peu plus en
difficulté alors on reçoit évidemment
beaucoup d'images de du front Mariana
pou des images de de neige est-ce que ça
veut dire que la situation elle est
figée pour longtemps ou pas forcément
euh alors Emmanuel vient de soulever la
question importante mais la question
cruciale en fait de dès le début c'est
que il faut comprendre que les
résultats sont indexés sur la é la
qualité d'aide militaire que les soldats
reçoivent s il y a une chose qui est
certaine c'est que l'Ukraine a
suffisamment de de forces armées et qui
sont d'une grande qualité qui sont euh
bien formé qui ont l'expérience du
combat et qui sont de de grande qualité
c'est une chose mais ensuite les
problèmes de de de manque de munition en
tous les cas n'ont jamais été réglé
pareil pour l'aviation souvenez-vous
l'Ukraine demandait la protection
aérienne et l'aviation dès le premier
jour de l'invasion parce que c'était
évident l'aviation et la protection
aérienne sont une composante absolument
cruciale non non non seulement pour les
offensives éventuelles mais également
juste pour la défense l'ucraine n'a
jamais euh eu cette
[Musique]
aide comme qu'on souhaitait dans les
volumes dans volum nécess avoir et
garder le contrôle on va dire de
l'espace aérien et je repose la question
euh euh météorologique en quelque sorte
est-ce que oui ou non ça ça a des
conséquences l'entrée dans dans dans
l'hiver euh sur la capacité des deux
camps d'ailleurs à progresser ou pas
alors si on regarde rétrospectivement il
y a eu déjà beaucoup de campagnes
militaires initiées par la Russie par
ailleurs dans le Donbass notamment euh
précisément en hiver euh l'invasion de
24 février
2022 a eu lieu à un iers également donc
il ne faut pas non plus se formaliser et
dire que c'est un c'est un facteur qui
change tout je voudrais juste rajouter
éventuellement ce que l'Ukraine est
quand même je rappelle l'Ukraine est
quand même relativement un grand pays un
peu comme la France à taille comparable
donc elle a des climats qui peuvent
varier tout comme le climat de centre de
la France est différent du climat de la
Côte d'Azur et différent du climat de la
côte atlantique donc ça c'est pareil
dans le Donbass on a l'
les neiges tant que je sache ne pose pas
tellement de problème mais plutôt par
exemple des vents qui peuvent être très
froid et très fort parce que ce sont des
steps donc c'est très c'est assez plat
et c'est très découvert si on va
vraiment vers le sud le sud de la région
d' Kerson là c'est un climat séiaride
normalement la neige n'y est pas un
problème Patrick Martin jeunier c'est
peut-être que c'est impossible de
répondre à la question que que je vais
vous poser sur le le le le bilan parce
que là on on a ce sentiment d'être dans
un bras de fer qui peut durer pend
encore des des semaines ou des mois ou
pour gagner quelques kilomètres il y a
des des milliers de morts est-ce qu'on
sait combien il y a eu de mort depuis le
début de ce conflit ou alors là on parle
environ de enfin euh 300000 300000
disons pertes il y a les morts et les
blessés hein et donc c'est ça mais du
côté russe c'est aussi la même chose
hein les pertes sont considérables des
pertes considérables depuis le début de
la guerre mais aussi le long du front on
parle d'une guerre d'attrition et on
voit ce que c'est qu'une guerre
d'attrition si je peux me permettre
j'étais à Verdin il y a 15 jours on peut
voir de quelle façon sa première guerre
mondiale a été meurtrière les morts on
est resté des mois et des mois comme ça
dans les tranchées à se battre et
fatalement c'est très meurtrier alors ça
y ressemble aujourd'hui ah oui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ça je ne le croyais pas
avant mais je suis allé sur place je
regarder là-bas à Verdin ce que ça avait
été le fort deement le fort de veau les
tranchés autour de Verdin et bien on a
ça a duré des mois c extrêmement
meurtrié j'ai la sensation qu'en voyant
cela et bien c'est exactement la même
chose euh les soldats Ukrainiens se
battent de façon héroïque avec les
moyens qu'ils ont les moyens occidentaux
c'est difficile aussi du côté russe il y
aurait quelques mutineries également
donc on voit bien que l'hiver va quand
même avoir un impact mais on voit bien
que Vladimir Poutine s'inscrit dans la
durée avec cette guerre avec cette
mobilisation de 170000 soldats
supplémentaires et il n'a pas peur il
sait que cette guerre va durer au moment
précisément où l'Ukraine rencontre
également des difficultés sur le plan de
l'aide internationale ça on va y revenir
évidemment en détail Matthieu quand je
vous écoute tous les trois sur cette
contreoffensive j'ai l'impression que le
problème il a été essentiellement
logistique il y a pas eu les hommes ou
les armes nécessaires est-ce qu'il y a
pas eu non plus un problème stratégique
euh je suis pas un expert à des
questions de défense ou militaire est-ce
qu' est-ce que est-ce que la est-ce que
avoir parlé autant de temps avant de
cette contreoffensive on l'impression
que tout était à ciel ouvert que tout
était connu et je ne sais pas de la
façon dont elle a été menée est-ce que
c'est ce sont les les les les bons les
bons points est-ce que ça a été
interrogé oui je crois que vous utilisez
le le bon terme autant la Russie n'a pas
de victoire militaire mais elle n'est
pas défaite stratégiquement c'estàdire
que dans le sens où elle est toujours là
Patrick l'a rappelé Mariana aussi il y a
une forte capacité de mobilisation et
l'opinion publique russe tient même si
l'opinion publique est de moins en moins
enclin à soutenir la Russie un sondage
et qui est sorti il y a un mois évoque
que depuis février dernier il y a une
diminution de 50 % de soutien à
l'opération militaire spéciale vous
évoquez où ça en Russie en Russie en
russiec vous évoquez les chiffres
patrickem rappeler que le nombre de
morts est à peu près équivalent sauf que
le nombre de d'Ukrainiens est est trois
fois inférieur qu fois inférieur rus si
on a 300000 d'un côté l'état-major
ukrainien il y a 2 semaines a évoqué
311000 russes soldat ruses qui qui sont
décédés mais ce qui est important c'est
de prendre en compte que pour un mort
c'est TR ou qu blessés donc ça veut dire
que ça bloque et ça fige effectivement
un constat particulièrement alarmant
donc oui sans doute que la manière dont
nous avons pensé la contreoffensive
n'était pas en soi un règlement du
conflit et on a sans doute pensé trop
vite que s'il y avait une reconquête
territoriale la Russie serait
affffaiblie hélas alors tout le monde
prend la parole des interventions assez
courtes si vous voulez parce encore
beaucoup de thèmes Mariana pour
commencer patri Martin trouv cette
question particulièrement intéressante
d'autant plus qu'on la pose rarement et
malheureusement nous av pas de réponse
mais il y a quelques éléments pour
nourrir la réflexion premièrement c'est
le fait que la Russie a fait sauter le
barrage de novakarovka donc en fait ça
nous pouvons penser éentu que qu'elle
l'a fait pour une raison et précisément
pour contrer la stratégie qui peut-être
était en place et qui a dû être amendée
donc peut-être que c'est et le deuxième
point moi j'ai envie dire c'est une très
bonne question mais je pense que quand
même c'est quand même lié à la question
des moyens parce que c'est c'est les
moyens dont on dispose qui définissent
les stratégies possibles Patrick Martin
votre avis sur d'éventuelles erreurs
stratégiques de de de voladimir Zelenski
on voyait dans le sujet que il y a
quelques voies qui commencent à s'élever
à l'intérieur en Ukraine mais les
ukrainiens et spécialistes du droit
constitutionnel ukrainien vont vous dire
que c'est pas monsieur Zelenski qui
commande c'est le chef militaire et donc
la stratégie militaire lui incombe alors
que chez nous dans notre droit
constitutionnel démocratique on dit le
chef de l'État c'est le chef des armées
lui qui donne des directiv a priori ce
n'est pas comme ça que ça se passe en
Ukraine et on voit bien qu'il y a des
difficultés le jalousenie l'a dit
également le chef des armées et puis
d'un autre côté on voit bien qu'il y a
des critiques larvées entre les deux
dirigeants zelensk qui dit ce sera
extrêmement difficile de reprendre le
donbas donc on voit bien que quelque
part on cherche alors non pas à
incriminer uniquement le manque de
moyens occidentaux mais il y aurait des
choix stratégiques qui seraient
aujourd'hui contestés oui on va écouter
volodimir zelensk c'était une Inter tion
le 12 novembre dernier il prévenait
disait l'hiver sera difficile pour le
peuple ukrainien on
l'écoute nous devons nous préparer à la
possibilité que l'ennemi augmente le
nombre de frapp de Dron ou de missiles
sur nos
infrastructures la Russie se prépare à
l'hiver et toute notre attention doit se
concentrer sur la défense et la réponse
au terroristes surt ce que l'Ukraine
peut faire afin d'aider notre peuple à
passer
l'hiver
on parlait de l'opinion russe à
l'instant mais et l'opinion ukrainienne
on va beaucoup employer le mot lassitude
dans ce débat pour parler des du soutien
occidental est-ce qu'il y a une
lassitude au sein de une partie je dis
pas de tout tout le peuple ukrainien
mais partie du peuplera alors j'ai envie
de dire que l'opinion ukrainienne était
Lass avant même la grande invasion de
202 parce que la guerre dure depuis 9
ans donc ça c'est un point numéro 1 deè
chose je je parlerai plutôt d'un moment
de réajustement parce que effectivement
même la société dans son effort de
résilience si vous voulez dans dans des
premiers temps était amené à croire que
avec une sorte de de de Fort un peu
surhumain un très intensif on pouvait y
arriver on pouvait arriver à des
résultats beaucoup plus significatif
beaucoup plus tôt euh je pense qu'il y
avait un moment
de
d'être psychologique en cela on c'était
nécessaire en fait pour tenir de de de
se d'essayer de se présenter à un
horizon euh parce que si si on se dit
tout de suite que ça va encore durer par
exemple 3 ans et que ça va être
extrêmement difficile là on n plus du
tout de force pour tenir donc là je
pense que d'un côté c'était important et
nécessaire mais d'autre côté c'est vrai
qu'il y avait toujours en flou par
rapport à aux armes euh occidentales bon
on va quand même y revenir oui qui
seront disponibles et là c'est ça c'est
pareil ça veut dire quoi vous très vite
vous ressentez quand même une sorte de
moment de creux dans dans dans dans le
soutien de du peuple ukrainien à à
Zelenski notamment alors non pas du
estce que ça s'exprime ça critique
contre le président h non pas du tout
pour l'instant il pas un petit peu quand
même il y a il y a le maire de Kief il y
a y a des voix discordantes quand même
ah alors là c'est je je je peux je peux
en parler alors ça c'est symptomatique
d'un autre processus
euh comme cela fait que euh cette guerre
à hte intensité dure donc la loi
martiale est en est appliqué depuis un
an et demi donc cela signifie quand même
la restriction de certaines libertés
notamment cela lique qu'il n'y a plus
des élections et attention quand on
parle des élections tout le monde se
concentre sur les élections par exemple
présidentielles mais les gens parfois
ils ont envie également de voter pour
des élections municipales parce que ce
sont des pouvoirs qui sont
oua vie politique un peu gel vouli
intervenir l'Ukraine est une démocratie
donc c'est tout à fait normal qu' a des
voix
dissidentes justement je pense que c'est
au contraire une preuve que l'Ukraine
n'est pas un pays qui vit seulement sous
la loi martiale vital kichco a émis un
certain nombre de doutes Victor
porochenko l'ancien président également
ce sont pas des alliés politiques ils
ont soutenu ésident mais pour répondre à
votre question c'est pas zinski qui mène
la guerre c'est les Ukrainiens donc
réduire la guerre au choix de zelinsk
serait réducteur oua premièrement parce
qu'il y a différents fronts comme ça a
été rappelé le front de Kerson n'est pas
le front de kkif à kkif ils ont les
Ukrainiens ont réussi après une
vaillante là pour le coup contreofensif
qui a marché en septembre 2022 récupérer
à certain nombre de des territoires qui
avaient été conquis par les Russes donc
je crois qu'il y a pas de lassitude par
contre il y a sans doute de la part du
présent zeninski une insuffisante prise
en compte des diversités politiques et
forcément la fin des élections ou
l'annulation des élections à cristallisé
cette opposition ouais c'est impossible
en quelques mots Patrick Martin
d'organiser des élections en pleine
guerre écoutez moi personnellement je ne
crois non pour parce que ils sont en
train aujourd'hui on va en parler la
semaine prochaine au Conseil européen de
négocier leur adhésion à l'Union
européenne or pour adhérer à l'Union
européenne faudra bien qu'un jour on
organise des élections Mariana disait
effectivement pourquoi pas des élections
municipales des élections législatives à
la Rada mine de rien même si ce pays
reste une démocratie n'en demeure pas
moins que le débat démocratique a été
mis entre parenthèses depuis le début de
la guerre donc il faudra bien pour s'en
sortir admettons j'espère pas mais que
cette guerre s'inscrive dans la durée
c'est ça ça dure encore 2 ans 3 ans il
faudra bien des élections avant et ce
sera effectivement un débat politique
interne à l'Ukraine alors on vous ouvrz
un chapitre un peu plus diplomatique
Mathieu je commence avec vous l'Ukraine
est-elle encore une priorité
diplomatique de la France alors depuis
l'attaque du Hamas en Israël le 7
octobre le dossierukrinien n'est plus
forcément au sommet de la pile même si
Emmanuel Macron se veut rassurant dans
un échange téléphonique avec son
homologue ukrainien le 18 octobre
dernier il a promis que la
multiplication des crises n'affaiblirait
en rien le soutien français et européen
à l'Ukraine qui demeurera aussi
longtemps que nécessaire fermé les
guillemets de son côté volodimir zelensk
s'est montré un peu plus diert précisant
que les deux hommes avaient discuté du
renforcement des capacités militaires de
l'Ukraine le président Macron et
moi-même a dit zinski nous sommes
concentrés sur les prochaines étapes du
renforcement de la défense anti-aérienne
des capacités de longue portée et des
capacités navales tout ça c'est pour la
version officielle mais officieusement
pourtant la diplomatie française
n'échappe pas au doutes aux
interrogations qui saisissent les autres
alliés occidentaux de l'Ukraine dans ce
conflit on l'a dit qui dure et se fige
est-ce que ça peut aller jusqu'à une
nouvelle approche un changement
d'approche de la part de Paris ce qu'il
a c'est qu'en 22 mois Emmanuel Macron a
quand même tenté beaucoup de choses hein
un si on se souvient conserver le fil du
dialogue avec l'agresseur dans un
premier temps en tentant de ramener
Vladimir Poutine à la raison puis en
prenant une victoire de l'Ukraine qui
humilie pas la Russie et puis qui
n'écrase pas la Russie de soutenir
lesffts de guerre ça c'était le deuxième
chose en livrant des canons même si on
n'est pas le pays qui a le plus livré de
d'armes à l'Ukraine donc des canons des
véhicules blindés avant de changer
d'approche quand même en septembre
dernier avec une visite du ministre de
la défense sur place qui a dit que en
gros il s'agissait plus de donner
maintenant le temps des session doit
doit devenir une exception a dit a dit
Sébastien Lecornu mais de mettre en lien
les Ukrainiens avec nos industriels de
défense en gros de négocier des contrats
troisème approche tentée mobiliser la
communauté internationale mais alors là
on a entendu des appels répétés
d'Emmanuel Macron notamment à la tribune
de l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU au pays
du Sud global en leur disant de ne pas
détourner le regard qu'il fallait qu'ils
agissent ce qui se thèse aujourd'hui
servent malgré eux ou secrètement avec
une certaine complicité la cause d'un
nouvel impérialisme souvenez-vous c'est
ce qu'il avait dit
à la rentrée 2022 ben tous ces appels là
sont quand même restés lettrre mortte et
puis 4ème approche accélérer
l'intégration européenne de l'Ukraine
alors Emmanuel Macron recevra d'ailleurs
demain à Paris le Hongrois Victor Orban
pour tenter d'éviter que ce dernier ne
sabote les discussion sur l'ouverture
des négociations d'adhésion avec Kief
qui doivent se dérouler la semaine
prochaine quand je vous écoute je me dis
qu'il il y a plus beaucoup de leviers ou
de cartte dans dans dans la Manche du
président Ben oui il y en a plus
beaucoup d'autant que il y a évidemment
l'inconnu on en parlera de la
présidentielle américaine qui hypothèque
sérieusement l'avenir et qu'à cette
inconnu s'ajoute une forme de lassitude
vous avez employé le mot qui touche de
nombreux alliés occidentaux de volodimir
Zelenski alors la perspective d'une
résolution militaire du conflit
s'éloignant de plus en plus de de
diplomates à Paris mais aussi en Europe
mise désormais sur une négociation comme
seule issue possible le problème c'est
que cette négociation ni Kief ni Moscou
ne veulent en entendre parler pour le
moment alors on va parler du Congrès
américain tout à l'heure je commence par
l'Europe évidemment avec vous Patrick
Martin jeunier ce Conseil européen la
semaine prochaine il sera crucial on
peut le dire avec quel risque de blocage
oui c'est un Conseil européen
exceptionnellement
important pour l'Ukraine les enjeux sont
considérables parce qu'on voit depuis
quelques semaines Victor Orban le
Premier ministre hongrois dire je ne
veux absolument pas d'ouverture des
négociations avec l'Ukraine pour
l'adhésion à l'Union européenne alors on
sait bien que derrière il est furieux
parce que l'Europe la Commission
européenne a bloqué l'argent du fond de
relance parce qu'il considère que la
Hongrie n'est plus un état de droit donc
on lui a confisqué son argent donc
certains estiment et c'est l'objet sans
doute de la réunion demain avec Emmanuel
Macron à l'élisé certains aimeraient que
et bien on lui donne de l'argent une
partie de son argent pour que cela
puisse débloquer son enfin en tout cas
éviter un espè de chantage chantage car
il pas d'autre terme et j'ai cru
comprendre que la Commission européenne
n'était pas défavorable effectivement à
ce qu'on donne une partie de argent du
fond de relance pour éviter un vetau
donc il y a Victor urbane mais faut pas
oublier les autres notamment le Premier
ministre slovaque qui ne veut plus
d'aide militaire à l'Ukraine donc on
voit bien que parmi les États européens
certains semblent aujourd'hui
effectivement très extrêmement réticent
pour poursuivre cette aide à l'Ukraine
qu'il s'agisse d'une aide militaire ou
d'une aide économique ou de l'ouverture
des négociations pour l'adhésion de ce
pays à l'Union européenne Emmanuel dupit
vous nous avez donné le chiffre de
l'aide militaire amé ain depuis le début
de la guerre au niveau l'Europe se situe
à quel niveau par rapport à cette a
alors 11 milliards pour les États-Unis
70 milliards pour l'ensemble des 27 pays
deunion européenne mais au-delà de du
blocage éventuel sans doute évident de
la part de Victor orbane il y a aussi le
blocage des 50 milliards d'euros que
l'Union européenne a promis depuis juin
dernier qui si elles ne sont pas votés
là ne seront pas débloqués donc c'est 50
milliards pour l'année qui vient et
autre élément important Joseph Borel
avait évoqué l'idée qu'il faille
renforcer la facilité européenne pour la
paix pour spécifiquement permettre à
l'Ukraine d'acheter sur étagère un
certain nombre de matériel militaire on
n parle plus donc là c'était 20
milliards supplémentaires ouais donc ça
ça revient ce que disait Mathieu tout à
l'heure sur un peu le changement de pied
de du ministère de la Défense on arrête
de donner maintenant vous discutez avec
nos industriels l'idée c'est c'est
évidemment que que que l'Ukraine puisse
acheter du matériel militaire mais
encore fautil que ENIT les moyens donc
l'ité c'était de lui donner un certain
nombre de moyens pour ensuite disposer
de ces matériels militaires mais comme
ça a très bien été dit en 2024 il y a
quand même des élections importantes non
seulement les élections américaines
certes mais on votera aussi en Russie il
y a 2 milliards de personnes qui vont
voter et donc un certain nombre de ces
pays auront l'idée selon laquelle leur
chef de gouvernement devra prendre des
décisions si oui ou non il soutient ou
continue de soutenir des pays qui sont
membres du G7 des pays qui sont membres
du G20 je pense notamment à l'Inde et
également donc c'est un élément
déterminant d'autant que ça peut peser
sur des scrutins locaux je vous poser
peut-être la même question sur les
États-Unis tout à l'heure mais sans
parleratunis ça va en tout cas poser sur
les scrutins européens il risque d'avoir
un changement de majorité en Bulgarie il
risque d'avoir un changement de majorité
en Autriche ou le parti d'extrême droite
avec Sébastien Kurtz risque de revenir
en pouvoir à l'automne prochain il y a
effectivement Robert Ficot en
Slovaquie peut poser sur les élections
européennes ça peuter aussi sur les
élections européennes du 9 juin car une
MAJ dor des 705 députés européens sont
soit conservateurs soit à droite du
parti populaire et disons qu'il a pas un
consensus absolu dans cette majorité
pour un soutien ou continuation d'un
soutien de haute intensité àrainei
soutiens indectible il y a celui du
secrétaire général de l'OTAN je propose
d'écouter tout de suite James
Stoltenberg ça arrive très souvent dans
les guerres que lorsque les gens se
rendent compte que cela peut durer
longtemps bien s cette exigence est
difficile d'un notre côté nous n'avons
pas
d'alternative l'alternative laisser le
président Poutine gagner est une
tragédie pour les Ukrainiens c'est
dangereux pour nous et cela aura un prix
élevé à long terme pour nous
tous
Mariana je rebondis sur ce que vient de
dire le secrétaire général de de
l'UTAN laisser laisser la main ou
laisser le terrain libre à Vladimir
Poutine ça nous coûterait encore plus
cher à terme mais exactement et par
ailleurs j'ai déjà rappelé que la guerre
dure depuis 9 ans et ce que les
Ukrainiens disaient en dès 2014 ne nous
laissez pas tomber comme ça parce que ça
aura des conséquences par la suite pour
le monde par ailleurs c'est pas un
hasard si si Trump est arrivé après
parce que justement le fait qu'on a
laissé euh un un
État autoritaire avec un leader fort
envahir une une partie de son voisin
d'occuper une partie de ses territoires
euh qu'on a quasiment on n'a rien fait
contre cette occupation cette annexion
euh ça a premièrement ça ça ça a
encouragé tous les leaders du même type
dans le monde c'est la première chose
mais beaucoup mais de manière beaucoup
plus dramatique c'est que l'Ukraine
avait abandonné euh tout son arsenal
nucléaire qui était le 4e arsenal
nucléaire au monde contre les garanties
de sécurité
je laisse les juristes discuter d
comment cétait écrit si c'était bien
écrit si c'était ficelé si c'était pas
ficelé si c'était respecté ou
non mais mais tous les régimes du monde
surtout tous les régimes autoritaires du
monde ils ont bien regardé ce qui s'est
passé ils ont vu que l'Ukraine n'a pas
n'a pas bénéficié de ces garanties de
sécurité qu'on lui promettait parce
qu'on lui promettait cela dans les
années 90 et tout le monde a compris que
le seul moyen de survivre c'est
premièrement de se nucléariser et d'être
agressif et et et nous continuons
toujours dans la même logique dans le
monde ça ça provoque encore plus de
conflit ou je voudrais vous entendre
tous les deux sur Patrick Martin Gier je
commence avec vous sur est-ce que cet
argument qui qui est l'argument premier
quand on quand on décide quand les
Occidentaux et l'Europe décide de
soutenir l'Ukraine c'est pour stopper
VAD Poutine et puis avec en tête quand
même le le le risque d'une contagion
est-ce que cet argument il il pèse plus
du tout ou il pèse encore quandme dans
la décision des Européens se dire si on
baisse la garde qu'est-ce qui peut se
passer après je crois qu'au niveau des
gouvernements au niveau des stratégies
politiques oui l'argument est toujours
le même on ne doit pas laisser gagner la
Russie en Ukraine le problème c'est que
derrière il y a les peuples nous sommes
des états il y a la démocratie on débat
et on voit bien qu'il y a des élection
et que je ne parlerai peut-être pas de
l'assitude mais il y a une certaine
fatigue lorsqu'on entend effectivement
il faudrait bien que cette guerre est un
terme et on entend cela aussi en Ukraine
donc on est toujours sur la même
stratégie politique et militaire mais en
Rev en revanche peut-être que les moyens
ne suivent pas toujours si on disait il
faut absolument que l'Ukraine et bien
gagne cette guerre on donnerait
immédiatement tous les moyens or ce
n'est pas le cas puisqueon vous parlerit
du Congrès tout à l'heure on voit bien
que en terme de moyens maintenant et
bien on atteint un certain plafond qui
fait que on naccorde pas l'ambition
stratégique avec les moyens militaires
Emmanuel DUP votre avis là-dessus un peu
la la même question et peut-être je peux
rajouter à ça est-ce que l'un des deux
pays peut gagner la guerre non aucun des
deux ne peut gagner la guerre et c'est
ça tout le problème d'ailleurs le chef
d'étatmajor Valérie zaluni le disait
récemment en disant que pour l'instant
c'est un front figé que les Ukrainiens
peuvent tenir au prix évidemment
absolument considérable du nombre de
victimes qui qui pose un problème par
rapport à la différence de de de de
capacité militaire de capacité humaine
tout court capacité humaine et et
matérielle donc encore une fois le le
front risque d'être figé pour l'hiver et
accessoirement ne pas occasionner des
conquêtes de territoire par contre ce
qui été dit précédemment et
particulèrement vrai les opinions
publiques sont quand même le nerf de la
guerre et Lyd Austin encore récemment
l'a dit line pardon on parle le
secrétaire à la Défense américaine la
Défense américain l'a dit en disant que
ce sont les opinions public qui
décideront si il faut et comment on peut
soutenir l'Ukraine et d'unz-y d'un point
de ce point de vuel on a aussi été un
peu naïf dans l'idée que le régime des
sanctions fonctionne on le voit bien les
chiffres sont sortis il y a quelques
jours l'Ukraine pardon la Russie gagne
plus d'argent maintenant par rapport à
l'exportation de pétrole que avant les
sanctions les sanctions sont bloquées
puisque le vetto hongrois et peut-être
slovaque fait que le 12e paquet de
sanction ne va sans doute pas être voté
lors du conseil ou alors ce serait la
pire des situations 26 pays laassne et
un laassigne pas donnant à la Russie une
victoire symbolique l'Union européenne
et desunis vis-à-vis du soutien à
d'Ukraine allez comme premis on va
parler maintenant des États-Unis et je
propose à Tam trê Tran Nui de nous
rejoindre tout de suite sur sur ce
plateau on l'a dit Tam bonsoir bienvenue
Washington principal fournisseur d'aide
militaire à l'Ukraine cela pourrait ne
pas durer oui puisque cette aide
militaire elle est suspendue à un vote
du Congrès lundi la Maison Blanche a
lancé un appel pour demander aux élus
américains de voter d'urgence une
rallonge à l'Ukraine de 61 milliards de
dollars pour la présidence américaine
c'est une question de civilisation
écoutez le conseiller à la sécurité
nationale de Joe Biden Jak
Sullivan voter contre un financement
supplémentaire pour l'Ukraine nuira à
l'Ukraine et aidera la Russie cela nuira
à la démocratie et aidera les dictateurs
nous pensons que ce n'est pas une bonne
leçon pour l'histoire et que chaque
membre démocrate et républicain du
Congrès devrait voter pour soutenir mais
voilà c'est un appel qui n'a pas
convaincu tout le monde loin de là
puisque' hierier lors d'une réunion du
Congrès bien les démocrates les
républicains ils se sont tout simplement
écharpés dans ce contexte volodimir
Zelenski qui devait intervenir en visio
dans cette réunion et bien il a annulé
son intervention sans plus d'explication
et quant à Joe Biden en fin de journée
il ne lui restait qu'une grande
frustration et cet argument un refus du
Congrès serait contraire aux intérêts
des États-Unis alors pourquoi ça ne
convint pas le camp républicain le camp
républicain il est divisé sur ce sujet
vous avez d'un côté et bien la tentation
isolationniste qui est incarnée par
Donald Trump pour qui tout l'argent
envoyé à l'Ukraine est dilapidé manque
de contrôle et puis vous avez une autre
aile chez les républicains qui est plus
favorable à l'aide à l'Ukraine et en
plus de ça et bien il y a des
fluctuations par exemple Mitch McConnel
le chef des républiquains au Sénat il a
longtemps soutenu l'aide à l'Ukraine et
hier il a déclaré qu'il appelait à voter
contre pour le vote qui a lieu
aujourd'hui à l'inverse le président
républicain de la chambre des
représentant Mike Johnson le speaker qui
vient tout juste d'être élu fin octobre
et qui est un proche de Donald Trump et
ben lui il a tourné kazak mais dans
l'autre sens il avait voté deux fois
contre des aides militaires à l'Ukraine
et voici ce qu'il a déclaré la semaine
dernière nous ne pouvons pas permettre à
Vladimir Poutine d'envahir l'Europe et
nous comprenons la nécessité d'aider
l'Ukraine il a appelé dans une lettre à
une négociation entre républicains et
démocrat quel est l'objet de cette
négociation c'est qu'il y a une
contrepartie qui est demandée par les
républicains un durcissement de la
politique d'immigration et du droit
d'asile un renforcement de la sécurité à
la front avec le Mexique et pour
l'instant les démocrates ils refusent et
donc ce mot lassitude il a-t-il une
lassitude de C ce grand allié américain
ben c'est ce qu'on peut penser les
États-Unis ont engagé des dizaines et
des dizaines de milliards de dollars
depuis juillet depuis février 2022
aujourd'hui la tension est par ailleurs
détourné par la guerre au proche- Orient
c'est ce qui explique que la rallonge
budgétaire discutée par le Congrès porte
à la fois sur l'Ukraine 61 milliards de
dollars et sur Israël 14 milliards de
dollars et c'est une aide pour le coup
qui fait plutôt consensus face à cela et
bien on a on a les responsables
Ukrainiens qui n'ont cessé d'alerter la
fin de l'aide américaine serait une un
scénario catastrophe pour kiief dont la
contreoffensive vous l'avait expliqué
n'a pas eu les résultats escomptés la
question qui reste aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir si la réunion houleuse d'hier au
Congrès reflète une vraie fracture entre
deux camps irréconciliables ou si c'est
un moment où chacun fait monter les
enchères avant un possible accord merci
beaucoup Tam Tran pour toutes ces ces
informations justement Patrick Martin
jeunier est-ce qu'on peut malgré tout
espérer un accord est-ce que c'est un
peu de la je sais pas quel terme employé
des des gesticulations internes ou des
jeux internes politiques et et qui
pourrai malgré tout déboucher sur un
ator qu quel est votre avis là-dessus
bah il me semble que c'est plus que des
gesticulations on est en plein débat
politique pour l'élection présidentielle
le camp républicain lui-même est très
divisé et il y a une poignée de
républicains très à droite trumpiste et
que se passe-t-il en réalité ils sont en
train de dire on a donné beaucoup
d'argent à l'Ukraine on n'en voit pas
nécessairement les conséquences
favorables la la contre-offensive et
bien n'est pas ce qu'on espérait ce qui
a été dit et surtout il faut privilégier
le contrôle des migrant à la frontière
mexicaine l'argent que vous avez passé
en Ukraine qui pourrait aller en Israël
c'est autant d'argent qui n'a pas été
mis dans le contrôle migratoire dans la
construction du mur au Mexique et c'est
pour ça que ça clapoté hier c'est à
cause de cela que le président Zelenski
n'a pas pu s'exprimer parce que le camp
républicain a bien dit qu'il est hors de
question de voter cette rallonge
budgetaire ils veulent désormais se
reconcentrer sur un débat national le
débat migratoire qui est celui du du
clan trumpiste c'est ça aujourd'hui et
donc ils ne sont plus pour une aide
inconditionnelle on parle de l'aide à
l'Ukraine mais c'est exactement vrai
également pour l'aide à Israël et donc
on voit bien aujourd'hui que les débats
effectivement sont importants je
mentionnerai enfin un courrier quand
même de la directrice du budget des
États-Unis qui a été adressé au
président du Congrès en les prévenant
que si cette aide complémentaire cette
rallonge n'était pas votée d'ici le mois
de décembre et bien ce serait
extrêmement dommageable pour le futur de
l'Ukraine Emmanuel Dupuis il y a aussi
une question de de capacité est-ce que
les Américains et les Européens
d'ailleurs sont en mesure
d'augmenter cet approvisionnement en
armes sans basculer dans une sorte
d'économie de guerre où est-ce que nos
industries sont sont finalement au
rupteurs d'une certaine façon poser la
bonne question Sébastien Lecornu notre
mise la défense a évoqué le fait que
nous devrions rentrer dans une économie
de guerre les Français n'y sont pas
préparés les Américains encore moins
même si l'élément électoral là aussi
compte car une bonne partie des
retombées des exportations militaires de
des États-Unis vers l'Ukraine ou vers
Israël va profiter à la base
industrielle et technologique américaine
60 % de l'argent qui est donné entre
guillemets à l'Ukraine revient aux
États-Unis donc ça c'est un élément sur
lequel même des républicains qui sont
rétifs à l'idée de voter pour l'instant
en faveur de l'Ukraine ne sont pas
insensibles dans un certain nombre de de
régions alors j'ouvre une toute petite
parenthèse je vous laisse donc après
quand on dit économie de guerre ça veut
dire quoi tiens d'ailleurs concrètement
ça veut dire que des industries qui qui
qui font autre chose basculent vers la
la
productionarm déjà on augmente la
cadence de production d'armement
d'accord au plus fort des combats
d'artillerie il y avait à peu près 30000
obus qui était tiré par jour si vous
prenez cela en considération vous voyez
que la production annuelle américaine
était un dans la capacité de fournir
autant de munitions que l'Ukraine avait
besoin le la France d'ailleurs a eu
promis d'augmenter de 1 million et demi
le nombre de de de de munitions qu'elle
pouvait fournir non pas seulement pour
l'Ukraine mais pour reconstituer son
stock par rapport aux munitions qu'elle
avait déjà donné en Ukraine donc pour
répondre rapidement votre question
l'économie de guerre c'est tout
simplement que nos industries de défense
se focalisent à livrer la quasi-ttalité
de ce que nous produisons vers l'Ukraine
ok je suis pas certain que l'opinion
publique française y soit totalement
préparée ouis Mariana p donc le le le
lien entre effectivement le le le
conflit Israël Gaza depuis le le 7
octobre
et ce ce ces livraison d'armes qui se
tarissent est-ce que vous faites ce lien
alors il me semble que c'est il est
encore tôt de le dire nous n'avons pas
les détails nous n'avons pas finalement
la liste de ce qu'utilise Israël
quotidiennement précisément et encore M
sont les mêmes voilà mais on a déjà
quand même vu des responsables
Ukrainiens euh dire que euh que
l'Ukraine recevait moins de munitions
d'artillerie parce que l'Israël utilise
les mêmes
munitions apparemment et ça par exemple
ça c'est très dommageable c'est critique
parce que l'Ukraine elle fait beaucoup
de combats d'artillerie parce que la
Russie elle mise énormément sur
l'artillerie elle a beaucoup
d'installations elle a beaucoup de
munitions donc c'est quand même critique
à ce que les Ukrainiens puissent tenir
et de quoi répondre ensuite il faut voir
vraiment cas par cas quelles sont les
armestil utilis ques sont les stratégies
parce que et combien ça va durer aussi
au Moyen-Orient combien de temps la
guerre va durer en Ukraine quels seront
les besoins là en ce qui concerne
l'Ukraine là je pense que tout a été dit
il faut vraiment accélérer quand même
cette réconversion en économie de guerre
parce que ça a été entamé mais bah c'est
comme avec tout toute autre livraison
c'est tout little il faut au bout d'un
moment il faut se
réveiller voilà oui je vrais qu' TER sur
pour pour il nous reste quelques minutes
parler de Vladimir Poutine qui est en en
ce moment dans les pays du Golf mini
tourné en quelque sorte il est aux
Émirats arabes unis aujourd'hui
discussion bilatérale à hucllos avec son
homologue émirati accueilli
vous voyez les images en grande pompe au
palais présidentiel et puis ensuite il
enchaînera avec une visite en Arabie
Saoudite euh Patrick Martin jeunier
est-ce que le président russe euh est en
train de voir grandir le nombre de ses
soutiens est-ce que il y a une sorte de
est-ce que ça rentre dans l'ordre vous
voyez ce que je veux dire oui je vois ce
que vous voulez dire d'un état paria il
passerait d'un état effectivement
fréquentable un peu plus fréquentable un
peu plus fréquentable mais il fréquente
d'abord ses alliés politiques aussi
l'aspect économique en terme de pétrole
euh soutenir le prix du pétrole du baril
de pétrole il y a des accords là-dessus
et surtout c'est la guerre entre Israël
et le Hamas à Gaza qui lui a permis de
rerentrer dans le jeu de la stratégie de
la géopolitique c'est cela parce que
finalement l'Ukraine ce n'est plus
tellement sa préoccupation ça s'inscrit
dans la durée et donc il voit bien
effectivement non obstant cette guerre
en Ukraine même si c'est très important
pour les Ukrainiens il veut montrer
qu'il est capable de passer à autre
chose et de continuer à peser sur la
scène internationale notamment par
rapport à ce conflit entre Israël et le
ramas ou Emmanuel Dupuit le la Russie je
crois va présider les l'organisation des
bricks donc Brésil Russie Inde Chine
Afrique du Sud à partir de du début de
l'année prochaine c'est à partir de
janvier 2024 janvier 2024 ça ça change
un peu la donne ça change beaucoup de
choses premièrement parce qu'un certain
nombre de pays vont sans doute être
beaucoup plus sensibles ou un discours
d'acceptation de la position russe
puisqu'ils veulent rentrer au sein des
bricks on évoque 40 possibles impétran
lors du prochain sommet qui aura lieu
donc en juillet prochain à Casan donc au
Tatarstan donc ça veut dire que la
Russie a une capacité d'agir sur un
certain nombre de pays qui jusqu'à
présent soutenez ou en tout cas
critiquer plus soutenez l'Ukraine et
critiquer plus verement la Russie ça
c'est un premier premier élément ensuite
ce qui se passe actuellement à Dubaï
avec la rencontre avec Mohamed Ben Zed
prouve que un certain nombre de pays
désormais ouvertement vont à l'encontre
de ce que nous aurions souhaité
c'est-à-dire une austracisation
diplomatique on pourrait aussi prendre
l'exemple de Sergey Lavrov qui malgré
notre tent la tentative de bloquer sa
venue à ceopier à l'occasion d'une
réunion de l'ce a malgré tout été
accueilli donc on voit bien qu'il y a
une forme de hélas de retour à la
situation avant le 24 février 2022 où la
Russie est un des pays cardinaux de ce
Sud global qui se cherche un leader vous
parliez de Sergey Lavrov le ministre
russe des Affaires étrangères ben il est
avec son homologue iranien signature
d'un document commun à propos des
sanctions internationales on écoute
Sergey
Lavrov nous travaillons actuellement à
la conclusion d'un nouvel accord
interétatique de grande envergure nous
venons de signer une déclaration sur les
voies et moyens de contrer d'atténuer et
de compenser les conséquences négatives
des mesures coercitive
unilatérale bien entendu il s'agit d'une
étape importante dans la coordination
accrue des efforts des membres de la
communauté international pour surmonter
les sanctions illégales dont les
États-Unis et leurs alliés ont fait un
substitut à la
démocratie un un mot de ces sanctions
pour conclure c'est vraiment notre
dernière minute vous en avez parlé tout
à l'heure donc je vous donne la parole
Patrick Martin jeunier euh comment c'est
possible quoi que que c'est combien vous
nous avez dit 12 trains de de de San 12e
train de sanction n'est pas été
finalement suffisamment efficace pour
affaiblir appauvrir la Russie je suis
quand même un peu plus prudent parce que
l'efficacité des sanctions économiques
c'est pas le temps de la communication
c'est pas le temps politique mais on
voit bien quand même l'Europe qui est un
partenaire essentiel sur le plan
commerciale a pris une 12è train de
sanction on ne peut pas aller bien plus
loin simplement il faut prendre en comp
la géopolitique la géostratégie la
Russie est un sous-continent à elle
toute seule donc elle a la capacité
d'être indépendante elle a la capacité
d'exporter du pétrole et donc c'est très
important pour il n'en demeure pas moins
que ces conséquences en terme de haute
technologie ont eu des effet notamment
pour l'équipement militaire et lorsque
Sergey Lavrov parle des conséquences de
ces sanctions il reconnaît quelque part
qu'elles ont été quand même qu commence
à être efficace merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat j'ai
rappelé Patrick Martin jeun le titre de
votre livre a-t-elle un avenir livre
publié aux éditions studirama j'ouvre